[Music]
celebrating summer tonight and we are
single how are you feeling I'm feeling
liberated Courtney Stodden
single and ready to mingle at OK
Magazine summer kick-off party
thank you like I'm making over a long
time right I'm meeting so many different
people and going out on so many
different days with celebrities and like
even uber drivers early late with a lot
of different people so I mean it it's
like crazy when I'm covering the
spectrum in the dating world so I'm
excited but I was crazy married but
crazier thing but watch out
are you already dipping back into the
dating pool are you taking some time oh
we're dating what are we looking for
everything I think has I've been married
for what climate hot here so I'm just
ready to just dive into dating and like
I don't know I'm just I'm just looking
for everything and seeing what I want
what I like it's kind of like I'm
finding myself I'm excited it's a new
chapter for me and I'm just having fun
but if I stumble across another marriage
[Music]
marriages on the table for the future
but maybe not right away
you never know are you and Doug still in
touch we are in touch I mean he's been
my rock when nobody else has been there
for me so just to have him cut out of my
life is kind of depressing to me because
he's been there for me you know so I
don't know we still talk and he's he's
so much to me still you know I hate to
say like a father figure but I mean the
age difference was 34 years so he's like
family